bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
spéciale proposée par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le vendredi 30 octobre
voici les titres
le président l'a annoncé c'est le retour
du confinement des mesures économiques
vont être mises en place pour venir en
aide aux entreprises
nous reviendrons sur le dispositif
thomas godefroy président de la ces pme
78 nous expliquera également comment
réagissent les petites et moyennes
entreprises
et si le confinement à démarrer c'est
aussi la toussaint ce week end
l'évêque auxiliaire de versailles bruno
valentin sera présent lors de cette
édition mais aussi le monde de la
culture et le monde du sport déjà
éprouvée par le premier qu'on veut
confinement et le couvre-feu réagi
seront à l'annonce du second avant cela
partons voir grégory canal e et
rédacteur en chef adjoint de la
rédaction de tv 78 avec le confinement
c'est le retour de l'attestation
obligatoire de déplacement explications
depuis quelques heures ce n'est pas une
mais trois attestations qui sont
disponibles sur le site du gouvernement
et sur l'application tous antico vide la
première vous la connaissez c'est
l'attestation de déplacement à
dérogatoire à remplir et à avoir en
permanence sur vous lorsque vous quittez
votre domicile un déplacement égale une
attestation à imprimer ou remplir
directement sur votre smartphone ou même
à remplir sur papier libre et les motifs
les voici des déplacements dans le cadre
de votre activité professionnelle si le
télétravail et n'est pas possible c'est
la première case vous cochez en revanche
la deuxième case si vous allez faire des
courses où vous allez retirer une
commande et les 3e et 4e mention pour
des déplacements dans le cadre de soins
de l'achat de médicaments ou pour motif
familial impérieux et l'assistance aux
personnes vulnérables ainsi que la garde
d'enfants sont autorisés à nouveau les
promenades les activités sportives
individuelles
les sorties pour les besoins de
animaux domestiques ces déplacements
doivent se faire dans la limite d'une
heure et dans un rayon d'un kilomètre
autour de votre domicile et des cases
existe aussi pour les déplacements de
personnes en situation de handicap pour
leurs accompagnants pour des
convocations judiciaires pour se rendre
dans des services publics ou pour des
missions d'intérêt général
enfin chose nouvelle c'est une nouveauté
tout en bas de cette attestation une
nouvelle case qui fait son apparition
pour aller chercher ou emmener votre
enfant à l'école
et justement afin de vous éviter de
remplir à chaque fois une nouvelle
attestation pour vous rendre au collège
à l'école au lycée un nouveau document
fait son apparition c'est le
justificatif de déplacements scolaires à
faire à cacheter par l'établissement
d'accueil de votre enfant cette
attestation est permanente et peut-être
conservé pendant toute la durée du
confinement
tout comme sept autres documents qui
cette fois ci pour les déplacements
professionnels
une attestation permanente qui existait
déjà lors du premier confinement elle
doit être achetée par votre employeur
une date de validité un moyen de
déplacement sont notamment a indiqué
quoi qu'il arrive hein vous devrez être
munis de l'un de ces trois documents dès
que vous quittez votre domicile chaque
contrevenant s'expose à 135 euros
damende les amendes en cas de récidive
peuvent grimper jusqu'à 3750 euros et
six mois de prison
merci grégory canales et depuis
l'annnonce de mercredi les supermarchés
s'organisent pour se re confinement tout
le monde se rappelle des files
d'attentes exceptionnelle pour s'acheter
des produits de première nécessité au
printemps dernier alors est ce que ce
sera de nouveau le cas
va-t-on réellement connaître ces
pénuries réponse de célia 400 go
le personnel de ce supermarché à
guyancourt s'affairent dans les rayons
des l'annoncent d'un confinement
mercredi soir le lendemain jeudi
beaucoup de personnes sont venues faire
quelques stocks les premières nécessités
l'huile la farine
le papier toilette le sopalin enfin tout
ce genre de produit donc oui on a vu un
afflux des clients sur ce genre de
produit
certains certaines familles de ces
produits comme l'huile on a fait + 60 %
sur la journée d'hier c'est des chiffres
qui sont totalement irrationnel il a
fallu ce vendredi matin réapprovisionner
les rayons de farine de pâtes de sucre
ou de papier toilette
mais ce super marché avait anticipé
cette affluence ils sont désormais mieux
préparé on commande aussi le colis
supplémentaires on va commander aussi
sur les ponts des rues et sur les gros
volumes on va commander sur du
conditionnement plus gros que d'habitude
on va passer du carton à la demie
palettes et de la palette et de l'année
palette à la palette pour de faux
certains enfants sont là dans tous les
cas il faut qu'on ait de la marchandise
ne faut surtout pas qu'on crée
nous-mêmes l'effet de panique
pas de panique en tout cas ce vendredi
matin les clients avaient des petits
chariots la plupart ne souhaite pas
consommer plus que d'habitude je vais
continuer à acheter au fur et à mesure
en fonction des besoins
mais je vais pas en fait me ruer sur les
rayons et tous les idées il faut aller
c'est aussi pour les autres donc
on vit au jour le jour si vous voulez
donc avoir un paquet supplémentaire mais
pas plus quoi c'est vrai on a envie de
le faire tous nos courses d'un coup dans
le sens où l'attestation faut la créer
pour sortir pour aller faire les courses
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya cette envie de
faire les courses mais comme je le fais
pour le mois généralement avec leur
confinement les supermarchés devraient
voir quand même leur chiffre d'affaires
augmenter durant le dernier confinement
les ventes en france ont été supérieures
de 10% à la moyenne
lors de sa conférence de presse jeudi 29
octobre le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance bruno le maire
a annoncé les nouvelles mesures de
soutien à l'économie
objectif permettre aux entreprises
fermées à cause du confinement de
résister à cette période
et juste avant justement d'accueillir
thomas-godefroy président de la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises des yvelines la ceppm 78 ont
fait le point sur les mesures avec
nicolas landry
c'est le retour de plusieurs recettes
qui ont fonctionné pendant le
confinement des dispositifs renforcés et
adapté par rapport à la situation
actuelle d'abord l'activité partielle va
être maintenu au moins jusqu'au 31
décembre 2020 avec une prise en charge
par l'état à hauteur de 84 % du salaire
net
les entreprises touchées par le
confinement pour en bénéficier de ce
dispositif
certains secteurs comme l'hôtellerie ou
la restauration conserve une prise en
charge intégrale par l'état ensuite les
fonds de solidarité les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés fermé durant le
confinement peuvent bénéficier d'une
aide mensuelle jusqu'à 10000 euros
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
des secteurs du tourisme de l'hôtellerie
restauration de l'événementiel de la
culture du sport qui reste ouvert
pendant confinement mais qui subissent
une perte du chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 50 % peuvent aussi bénéficier d'une
aide mensuelle jusqu'à 10000 euros
enfin toutes les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés qui rencontre une baisse de
leur chiffre au delà de 50 % peuvent
obtenir une indemnisation pouvant aller
jusqu'à 1500 euros par mois
il ya aussi les exonérations de
cotisations sociales
elle est totale sur les cotisations
sociales pour les entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés fermés administrativement
les pme du tourisme de l'hôtellerie
restauration de l'événementiel de la
culture du sport qui reste ouvert
pendant
non mais qui perdent 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires et au delà seront
exonérées de cotisations sociales
patronales et salariales
enfin les prélèvements des travailleurs
indépendants seront suspendus pour ceux
qui connaissent une fermeture
administrative les exonérations seront
total les pge les prêts garantis par
l'état peuvent être demandés jusqu'au 30
juin 2021
le remboursement de ce prêt peut être
étalés jusqu'à 6 ans l'état propose
aussi des prêts directs aux entreprises
sans solution de financement jusqu'à
10000 euros pour les entreprises de
moins de dix salariés jusqu'à 50000
euros pour les entreprises de 10 à 49
salariés
dernière mesure un crédit d'impôt sur
les loyers à hauteur de 30% du montant
des loyers abandonné principales
bénéficiaires les entreprises de moins
de 250 salariés
fermée administrativement ou appartenant
au secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration
et tourisme
et nous accueillons thomas godefroy
bonsoir et bienvenue
on sort on l'a entendu des mesures vont
être mises en place mais avec ce
confinement dans quel état d'esprit se
trouvent les chefs d'entreprise
actuellement aujourd'hui à une très
forte inquiétude sur le sur le
département d'études qui existe depuis
déjà un peu plus d'un an nous à la suite
du premier confinement à la cpam des
yvelines on avait fait un sondage auprès
d'un peu plus de 1000 entreprises du
département
on avait déjà 52 % des personnes qui ont
répondu au sondage qui pensaient ne pas
pouvoir maintenir leur activité au-delà
de 2021
donc il y avait déjà une inquiétude qui
était très forte à ce matin le téléphone
n'a pas arrêté de sonner c'est un coup
de bambou un coup de massue pour
beaucoup de commerçants et notamment
enfin c'est principalement les
commerçants du centre ville qui sont en
difficulté qui se retrouvent fermé qui
comprennent pas forcément la mesure
pareil pour les restaurateurs enfin tous
ceux qui ont pris des mesures fortes et
coûteuse pour améliorer leur situation
sanitaire et améliorer l'accueil de
leurs clients qui malgré tout se
retrouve fermé on quand même entendu le
gouvernement a annoncé des mesures d
aide économique
est ce que pour vous elles sont
suffisantes et pourquoi alors les
mesures sont très fortes
très honnêtement je pense que on peut
tous d'accord dessus il ya des milliards
qui sont tes pensées le ont été très
heureux qu'au niveau de la ceppm d'une
partie des loyers qu'ils soient pris en
charge
dile 01 je le rappelle c'est bien ça
alors dix mille euros c'est sûr plus tôt
la perte de chiffre d'affaires qui peut
être prise en charge par l'état et il ya
une incitation pour les propriétaires
pour les bailleurs de d'exonérer des
loyers il ya des avantages fiscaux pour
les propriétaires qui ne feraient pas
payer de loyer aux petites entreprises
du département et de toute la france
d'ailleurs pour les aider puisque les
aides ne couvrait pas jusqu'à présent le
loyer donc oui les aides sont
importantes pour être très clair
évidemment qu'on peut toujours faire
mieux mais je pense qu'il n'est pas
possible au niveau de l'état de toute
manière de couvrir la totalité de la
perte de
de revenus on estime la fourchette est
très large entre 40 et presque 100
milliards en fonction des études par
mois de confinement de revenus perdus
par les entreprises évidemment nous ce
qu'on aimerait à la cpm s'est pas avoir
de l'aide mais c'est à voir que chaque
entreprise puisse avoir dû travailler
puissent ouvrir dans des conditions
restreintes mais ouvrir quand même pas
ce que l'on cherche pas des aides
recherche des carnets de commandes
évidemment est-ce qu'elle va être un
petit peu votre rôle en tant que
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises je le rappelle la ceppm
particulièrement dans les yvelines
vous disiez justement tout à l'heure que
votre téléphone n'arrêtait pas de sonner
quel va être votre rôle pendant ce
confinement notre rôle d'une manière
générale il est triple on est là pour
porter la voix donc pour représenter les
entreprises du département pour les
défendre quand il ya besoin et pour les
soutenir quand il y en a besoin
là on va être comme tout le monde on a
trois salariés à la cpam des yvelines
ils seront au télétravail on est vrai de
fermer ou aurait de fermer au public
tous les événements qu'on devait
organiser sont annulés sont fermées donc
le gros de notre activité ça va être de
flécher de permettre aux chefs
d'entreprise qui nous sollicitent d'être
fléchés vers la bonne aide parce que
l'état a mis en place on l'a vu juste à
l'instant de très nombreuses et de très
importantes aides on en a recensé plus
de 400 pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
alors toutes ne sont pas liées aux
copies de certaines existait déjà avant
mais elles vont dans des domaines très
variés ça sera évidemment le coc vide
mais aussi l'import et l'export le break
site la digitalisation la mobilité avaya
le très nombreuses aides
il est impossible pour une tpe du
département qui n'a pas de directeur
financier de services de ressources
humaines de savoir à quelle aide à la
halle droit donc là notre mission
principale ça va être ça ça va être
d'aiguillés d'aiguillés l'entreprise
vers la chambre de commerce 20 le
tribunal de commerce vers tel ou tel
organisme qui va pouvoir l'aider
on va les aider aussi à monter leur
dossier et on va créer des webinaires
pour les informer au fil de l'eau sur
les actualités juridiques et fiscales et
très rapidement un noël la période de
noël comment vous la sentez bien la
période de noël à représente entre un
quart et un tiers du chiffre d'affaires
pour bon nombre de commerçants notamment
des centres villes on espère que le
confinement même si personnellement j'ai
pas trop on espère que le confinement
sera terminé pour eux il ya une vraie
injustice de ce côté là entre les petits
commerçants qui sont fermés les grandes
chaînes de distribution qui puisse être
ouvert donc on espère qu'on va pouvoir
ouvrir et que les français vont nous
écouter et faire travailler des
commerces de proximité plutôt que les
réseaux digitaux où les prochaines
courses ou pour un petit peu les
entreprises du département
bien merci à thomas godefroy d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau
justement comment réagissent les
commerces dits non essentiels évidemment
cette nouvelle fermeture entraîne de
nombreuses incertitudes économiques
les petits entrepreneurs réfléchissent à
une stratégie de subsistance
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban et patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est un second coup dur pour certains
commerçants à nouveau forcé de fermer
pour frédéric sucrées qui avait déjà dû
retarder l'ouverture de son magasin de
course à pied en jouant à cause du
premier confinement la sentence est
difficile à accepter
certes avec un assouplissement mais
encore une fois les les commerces en
pâtissent
c'est compliqué c'est difficile ces
incertitudes alors il ya un dicton qui
dit entreprendre c'est apprendre à
oublier ses certitudes et vivent
l'expérience de l'incertitude et bien je
peux vous dire que la clé l'expérience
de la certitude suis en train de me la
forge et ayant reçu leur dernier client
en magasin ce jeudi 29 octobre les
commerces non essentiels cherche des
solutions pour s'adapter rapidement
effectivement je vais toujours devoir
trouver des alternatives proposées aux
clients des rendez vous
privatif proposé peut-être des
livraisons à domicile
je suis en train d'y réfléchir et tout
ça effectivement j'ai de voir le mettre
en place très rapidement mais qui nous
dit qu'il n'y aura pas une troisième
vague qui arrivera en janvier ou en
février qu'on va devoir de nouveau fermé
donc c'est ce manque de perspective qui
est compliqué et difficile à vivre
d'autant que les aides apportées par
l'état lors du premier confinement
n'étaient pas jugées suffisantes par les
entrepreneurs
on a eu 1500 euros pour deux mois de
fermeture avec deux salaires de gérante
donc oui j'ai confiance qu'on puisse pas
aider tout le monde mais
c'est trop bas pour pouvoir aider une
entreprise à sion démons on va on va
boire on va mettre une stratégie en
place on va faire ce qu'il faut pour
pour survivre survivre
c'est donc le mot d'ordre pour les
petits commerçants yvelinois qui avance
une fois de plus à l'aveuglé bonsoir et
bienvenue monseigneur bruno valentin
vous êtes évêque auxiliaire du diocèse
de versailles et vous êtes avec nous
parce que l'actualité c'est évidemment
aussi le drame qui est survenu au sein
même d'une église l'église notre dame à
nice jeudi 29 octobre
l'église catholique est une nouvelle
fois touché par un acte terroriste
on se souvient bien évidemment de
l'assassinât du père jacques hamel à
saint-etienne du rouvray en 2016
quelle a été votre réaction en apprenant
ce nouvel attentat
une immense peine évidemment une immense
peine pour les victimes pour leur
famille une grande inquiétude aussi une
grande inquiétude pour notre pays parce
que on ne peut pas au fond segmenter les
attentats veaux sont deux des victimes
il faut voir qu'il ya un fil de sang qui
relie l'attentât denis celui de conflans
sainte honorine ya quinze jours dans
tous ses actes
c'est le même islamisme qui est à
l'oeuvre et ce cataclysme la mise mais
c'est la fraternité ont font le point
commun entre toutes ces attentats c'est
une volonté de l'islamisme aujourd'hui
de détruire la fraternité qui est le
ciment de notre pays et donc jeu à
chaque acte qui porte un coup nouveau à
notre cohésion sociale de cette manière
grandis mon inquiétude et dans les
yvelines justement vous parler
d'inquiétude est ce que l'on quitte se
fait sentir aussi au diocèse de
versailles
on est extrêmement vigilant ou
extrêmement mobilisés on est en lien
très étroit avec le préfet parce que
à conflans à nice ce à quoi on assiste
c'est au fond à l'embrasement de vapeur
de haine qui sont aujourd'hui diffusées
sur tout le territoire français et donc
dans les yvelines comme ailleurs rien
que hier il ya eu une alerte assez
sérieuse à sartrouville
on a eu aussi des inquiétudes sur la
ville de versailles donc on est au
quotidien très en lien avec le préfet et
les forces de police avec qui les
collaborations seront très bonne pour
répondre à cela le premier ministre a
annoncé une surveillance renforcée alors
aux abords des écoles mais aussi des
lieux de culte qu'en pensez vous est ce
que pour vous ça va être suffisant oui
ce sera suffisant c'est cette phrase
suffisant et et moi je suis vraiment
heureux que le gouvernement est accepté
cette demande du président des évêques
que les messes de la toussaint y compris
les messes du lundi 2 novembre jour où
nous prions pour les morts soit encore
possible et ouvert à tous je crois que
spécialement dans l'année que nous
venons de vivre spécialement avec toutes
ces familles qui n'ont pas pu vivre au
cours du printemps des sépultures avec
le recueillement qu'elle aurait souhaité
pouvoir se retrouver dans les églises
dans les cimetières prendre le temps du
recueillement et de la prière pour les
défunts et spécialement important et
donc oui tout sera mis en oeuvre pour
que ces temps de recueillement on se
vivent paisiblement dans les yvelines
et justement vous évoquez la toussaint
c'est aussi l'actualité ce week-end même
si c'est le premier week end de
confinement avant de vous poser quelques
questions à ce sujet est
particulièrement ce week-end comme de
nombreux commerces jugés non essentiels
les fleuristes par exemple vont baisser
leur rideau à partir de lundi mais donc
ils ont tenu un sursis pour ce week end
important pour leur profession on écoute
une fleuriste de montigny le bretonneux
au micro de mélanie poquet et patrick
jacques de dixmude
en ce jeudi après-midi les clients se
succèdent anniversaire cadeau pour un
proche ou simple coup de pouce pour le
commerçant les commerçants qui sont là
depuis longtemps et bah c'est un petit
coucou on les soutient voilà ils sont là
et on sera là dès lundi 2 novembre les
salariés de cette fleuriste seront à
nouveau au chômage partiel
mais les professionnels ont obtenu un
court répit en ce week-end de la
toussaint
un soulagement pour catherine phalempin
en mars dernier elle a dû se résoudre à
jeter 100 mille euros de marchandises on
a reçu tous nos chrysanthèmes mardi
mercredi et si on fermait ce soir les
gens avaient pas forcément le temps de
pouvoir aller sur les cimetières en même
temps contrairement au premier
confirmant les cimetières reste ouvert
je sais que c'était pas passer donc
qu'on va pouvoir quand même s'organiser
les gens qui travaillent qui peuvent pas
venir aujourd'hui vont pouvoir venir
dans le week-end dimanche mais vie
catherine fermera ses portes pour
respecter le confinement ou du moins
n'accueillera plus de public
comme beaucoup de commerces elle
proposera un driver des livraisons sur
la ville nouvelle avec l'espoir de
reprendre une activité pour noël
deuxième période de forte activité après
la fête des mères on l'a donc entendu
les ce fleuriste ont un sursis ce week
end vous m'avez évoqué également que la
messe de la toussaint était et est
comment dire maintenu vous me le
confirmer à la fois la toussaint qui est
le 1er novembre
et aussi c'est nouveau d'aujourd'hui on
l'a appris les messes du 2 novembre du
lundi 2 novembre qui est le jour de
prière pour les morts dans le calendrier
catholique sont elles aussi maintenu
donc j'imagine que c'est un soulagement
pour vous oui oui c'est un soulagement
parce que vraiment je crois que
l'empêchement de ces célébrations si
spécifique si porteuse d'espérance et de
paix face à la mort aurait été une
blessure profonde pour beaucoup
comment ça va se passer après ce
week-end du coup après ce week end de la
toussaint et après ceux de novembre
alors le dans le même courrier au
présent la république où il demandait de
pouvoir c'est vrai tout ça le président
des évêques demandé aussi que les messes
du dimanche demeure comme un motif
dérogatoire possible pour sortir de chez
soi ça n'a pas été accordé et on le
regrette beaucoup parce que
on regrette qu'au fond cette dimension
de la prière ensemble soient jugés non
essentiels par le gouvernement et on va
continuer à demander on va continuer à
discuter
en attendant
tout n'est pas post ou n'est pas fermée
et en particulier les églises restent
ouvertes donc ce que nous allons
encourager dans les yvelines
c'est vraiment que les fidèles habitent
leur église
voilà puisqu'ils peuvent dans le cadre
de l'heure de promenade personnelle
passée dans l'église qu'ils n'hésitent
pas à venir y prendre un temps de
recueillement un temps de prière
personnelle
ils y seront bien accueillis les prêtres
font l'effort de s'y rendre disponible
pour un temps de dialogue pour un temps
d'écouté pour ceux qui veulent recevoir
le pardon réglé puisque nos églises
restent ouvertes habitons nos églises et
ben merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau monseigneur bruno
valentin dans l'actualité également ce
nouveau confinement va également avoir
un impact sur le sport amateur
les compétitions sont une nouvelle fois
à l'arrêt et ce pendant les quatre
prochaines semaines
les explications et réactions avec
michael almy d'euros bis repetita pour
le sport amateur ce nouveau confinement
va une nouvelle fois perturbé la
pratique sportive pendant au minimum
quatre semaines pour l'espoir
l'intérieur la fédération française de
handball avait été l'une des premières a
été la compétition au moins jusqu'en
décembre
tout comme la fédération française de
volley-ball pour le basket les
compétitions stop également jusqu'à
cette période mais les dirigeants
s'attendent à un redémarrage des
compétitions pour le début d'année
prochaine
la fédération de basket arts au moins
dit qu' il y aurait une inertie de
quinze jours quand les rencontres
pourrait reprendre pour permettre aux
équipes de se ré entraîner les de
manière à assurer une certaine équité
sportive et surtout une intégrité
physique de la part de tous les sportifs
qu'ils quelques sous quel que soit le
niveau auquel ils jouent pour le
football ce mercredi matin la fédération
française a annoncé la suspension des
compétitions de ligue 2 districts des
championnats nationaux du national 2 et
3 ainsi que la coupe de france et les
championnats nationaux jeunes cette
mesure s'appliquera au minimum jusqu'au
1er décembre un casse tête en vue pour
les instances ça pose la question n'a
pas encore pris de décision mais
on va y réfléchir maintenant c'est les
coupes parce qu'on a les championnats la
côte est mais les coupes des yvelines
d'autre part on avait déjà les coupes
les coupes futsal
qui était calé comme futsal seniors qui
avait dont il avait été décidé qu'elle
n'aurait pas lieu maintenant la question
va se poser pour l'ensemble des coupes
de toutes les catégories des seniors les
u18 les u16 les u14 des féminines et
c'est parce qu'il va falloir sans doute
se consacrer uniquement au championnat
le rugby amateur se met également en
pause jusqu'à début janvier au minimum
la fédération a également annoncé
l'annulation des phases finales pour
permettre aux championnats de se jouer
jusqu'au bout pour éviter la saison
blanche
nous faisions contre faut de mauvaise
fortune bon coeur en ayant là encore la
possibilité de jouer désormais il faut
vous participer à l'effort national
le plus dur reste à venir maintenant de
rester compétitif de garder le contact
avec nos licenciés et nos partenaires
seule interrogation la pratique ou non
du sport par les mineurs il pourrait
participer à des entraînements
le sujet est encore sur la table depuis
le mois de mars le monde culturel est
lui aussi touché et l'activité est aussi
au ralenti avec ce second confinement
les manifestations vont devoir être
annulé ou reporté des mesures comprises
par les artistes yvelinois pourtant une
inquiétude quant à l'avenir se fait
largement ressentir réaction avec justin
brazy le confinement un nouveau coup dur
pour les artistes qui viennent tout
juste de s'adapter au couvre-feu pour
l'heure dans le flou le milieu culturel
n'est pourtant pas surpris on s'en
doutait un an
on imaginait bien que ça n'allait pas
durer ce qui nous inquiète c'est en fait
de repartir peut-être un petit peu en
décembre pour qu'après en janvier et
vont friandises bas confiné
le problème c'est qu'on aa perspective
d'avenir ça qui est inquiétant
hier devant l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre jean castex s'est dit
favorable au maintien des répétitions
tournage ou encore enregistrements une
décision qui rassure je n'en rendent de
morale pour pouvoir répéter quand même
sur la période
comme jésus jésus du 16 au 20 novembre
pour reprendre une semaine de
répétitions plus aboutir à une captation
vidéo
autre inquiétude de la marge de
manoeuvre pour créer de nouveaux projets
culturels est réduite avec toutes ces
mesures là je vois pas comment
il va y avoir de nouvelles propositions
de spectacles je vais mal à passer des
investisseurs qui veulent créer des
nouveaux projets et c'est trop compliqué
en ce moment donc là c'est vrai que les
projets déjà existants si les artistes
peuvent répéter techniciens continuent à
travailler
c'est une bonne chose mais pour l'avenir
jeu compliqué moi je le vois dans la vie
de tous les jours au niveau des avis
d'audition il ya enfin c'est normal mais
y'a plus rien donc il n'y a pas beaucoup
de perspectives normal quoi
bilan les artistes yvelinois sont
solidaires et qu'on prenne les mesures
sanitaires
ils savent qu'ils vont devoir être
patient mais espère revenir sur scène
rapidement
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canal et avant cela
pourrait revoir toutes les émissions sur
le site internet tv 78 points com ou sur
notre application mobile tv 78 et même
confiné je vous souhaite un très bon
week-end et une très belle soirée
[Musique]